I know you don't like to talk about
something about your like sex sexual
life and in relationships I know you
don't like talking I don't mind talking
about it I I hope you know I'm gonna do
a little blessing on you man okay
I hope to god the Lord that you have a
child in the next three years in their
volleyball on the pool deck a sports
outfit we can't decide if no we're gonna
have that every time I gotta throw him
under the room I have one I can tell I
had dreams of I'd visions of it what do
you know I still have to they gonna hit
burden is not on you you can just show
up and do whatever the [ __ ] you all of
my guys do all the work
do what work that lorica yeah yeah yeah
don't let the toes doctor you see what
happens yeah do this how can Vietnamese
soup right there all right if you say
Vietnam again huh huh love that live in
Vietnam and you have it okay I've been
in the Binh Thanh market oh yeah you
know you were there right yeah which is
fun I stayed at the star hotel
[Laughter]
Vietnamese oh yeah you were in Asia huh
yeah yeah it's not Asia Vietnam Vietnam
do you go to brothels ever know you've
never been to a brothel here's what
happened so I got to Vietnam right right
and we get to Vietnam and and the taxi
driver we just wanted to go see anything
right and we get in and the first thing
I do is take you to a place where you
can buy sex if you want it if you want
sex you know and I was 22 years old I
think when this happened so who knows if
I wonder or not so anyway this guy takes
his we don't know that though we think
he's just you know we told him like Oh
take us to supermarket take us to star
hotel take us to something you know the
American war that's what they called it
there right so so this guy was driving
as he drops off it's a pet shop so we go
in and they got [ __ ] pets you know
what I'm saying and I'm but you know I
grew up around pets and you know I know
about some pets and I'm like oh this
would be great you know
see what pets they have over here and so
they have large parrots parakeets and
parrot lips which are small parents and
so we're [ __ ] look at all these
parrots and [ __ ] next you know what my
buddy kind of moves into the back of the
there's like a curtain II moves back
behind there and next thing I know my
other buddy and the sub this lady comes
out and gets me in him next you know
we're all back there and it's a
prostitution and they do in process
instead of got the birds up front and
it's just a it's a decoy you know the
birds at us up they're faking it none of
them even want to go home to new
people's homes and in the back they're
trying to suck you out what do you mean
yeah trying to suck you out of your
dicks out of you yeah through your dick
hole yeah yeah yeah I snuck you out of
your dick just like normal like they do
in America but they're trying to do it
there yeah and they're hiding behind
pets doing it yeah and that that
honestly broke my heart because these
animals don't know that yeah it's a wake
up every day thinking they got a chance
to find a new home that day yeah that
just 20 30 feet away and a little bit of
drywall yeah you know and a cash
register that people are sucking people
out of each other when I was in Thailand
before I met you babe yeah only once
yeah and when I like every day to this I
wish every day to this brothel right oh
and one day you know I picked this girl
we went upstairs and you want to hear
joy mm-hmm
you want to see joy hmm we're laying
there and I'm trying to get erect mm-hmm
I couldn't get it rock Jesus so I looked
during I go you know what I'm still
gonna pay you hmm
but you don't have to have sex with me
Wow the joy on her face I've never seen
I've never seen joy like that man it was
like thank you like she was crying um ah
yeah that's never happened there's like
babe we just sat there and watched TV
all night
Wow
yeah so you know pretty woman if they
okay I don't work for the light I do
yeah you know you made a hooker watch
television with wish you could've been
out or like I feel that I am TV or
something yeah lightwork yeah yeah
that's Wow huh
[Music]